[Music]
as you know the council is updating its
local plan
this is not a complete update of the
whole plan it is what is known as a
partial update
this means that we are updating certain
parts which includes topics that our
previous local plan inspectors
recommended
we are at quite an early stage of the
process so this video shares our
progress and provides information on a
consultation where you can have your say
please look at the documents and let us
have your comments by friday the 4th of
february 2022
don't forget this is only the start of
the local plan process
after we have gathered your views at
this stage of the process and compiled
further evidence we hope to publish a
draft plan in 2022
the draft plan will set out the detailed
policies and proposals for the area up
to 2040
there will be another chance for you to
comment before the draft plan is
finalized
as part of this partial update we have
published two key studies
the first is an update of the housing
needs assessment which identifies the
amount of housing the council needs to
allocate land for up to 2040
in line with government guidance and
provides more information about local
housing needs
the second is an update on the retail
and leisure study which indicates that
there is a little additional retail
floor space needed until 2040.
at this stage we have also published the
draft scoping report for the
sustainability appraisal of the local
plan
we have to assess the draft plan against
a range of social economic and
environmental criteria
and the draft scoping report proposes
what those criteria should be
this report has had comments from
natural england the environment agency
and historic england but we would like
to hear your comments on whether we have
identified the right criteria
we have also published two short
discussion papers on which we would
appreciate your views on these two
the first is about how we decide where
the focus of development should be
up to 2040.
in the adopted local plan the focus is
firstly on the towns and then the larger
villages
and the areas next to them and this was
agreed by the inspectors who looked at
the draft plan in 2019
the council needs to consider whether to
continue that focus or to look at
another option
the second is about the amount of jobs
we need to plan for up to 2040
kent county council have carried out
some work for us that suggests that we
need to plan for sites and buildings to
support around 11 000 jobs we would like
to hear people's views on the range and
number of jobs suggested
we have also reopened a call for sites
it is important that the sites the
council identifies to meet the local
development needs are suitable
available and deliverable
so it would be good to hear from agents
and landowners who believe they have
such sites which we can consider
if you would like to speak to one of the
local plan team before making comments
please get in touch
[Music]